is there something
you can say concrete about the
mysterious gap between
the subset ml and the bigger ai
what's missing what's what do you think
i mean obviously it's
totally unknown not totally but in part
unknown at this time but
is it something like with pat langlais
is it knowledge
like expert system reasoning type of
kind of thing so
uh ai is bigger than ml but ml is bigger
than ai this this is kind of the real
the the real problem here is that
they're really overlapping things that
are really interested in slightly
different problems i tend to think of ml
and there are many people out there are
going to be very upset at me about this
but i tend to think of ml being much
more concerned with the engineering of
solving a problem
um an ai about the sort of more
philosophical goal of
of true intelligence and that's the
thing that motivates me even if i end up
finding myself
living in this kind of engineering-ish
space i've now made
made michael jordan upset but you know
it's it's it's
to me they just feel very different
you're just measuring them differently
your
your your sort of goals of where you're
trying to be are somewhat different yeah
but to me ai is about trying to build
that intelligent thing
and typically but not always
for the purpose of understanding
ourselves a little bit better machine
learning is
i think trying to solve the problem
whatever that problem is now that's my
take
others of course would disagree
you